volcanic eruptions
can last for weeks months or
even years this
violent event is terrifying but
what if another storm say a tornado
or a hurricane combined with a volcanic
eruption
could it really happen
how long would it last
and if a volcano and a tornado combined
what could it throw at you
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if a tornado hit an active volcano
tornadoes only form during giant
thunderstorms called
supercells and according to george
kurunis
storm chaser and host of angry planet
supercells are already frightening
they're the biggest storms on planet
earth they're i've seen ones that have
been twice the height of mount everest
all that energy rotating around produces
torrential flooding
hail to the size of baseball or larger
vicious lightning and that rotation can
come all the way to the ground
and produce massive tornadoes could one
of these
massive tornadoes strike an active
volcano
let's back up a bit before we get into
the details we need to
visit the basics for a tornado to happen
you need just the right ingredients when
you're trying to forecast a tornado you
have to try and make a three-dimensional
picture of the atmosphere from the
ground all the way up almost to space
the moisture humidity wind patterns wind
shear all of these different ingredients
and if something is off just ever so
slightly it just wrecks the whole recipe
so what are those ingredients well first
you need an updraft which can happen
when cold air comes in
and shoves warm air higher into the
atmosphere
then you need winds to change direction
at different atmospheric heights
as the warm air rises it starts to spin
if there's enough spin then that
column of air rotates until it makes
contact with the ground
and now you have a tornado
volcanoes form when magma escapes from
earth's core
through a crack in earth's crust in some
volcanoes
the magma is too thick and traps gas
bubbles
eventually this creates so much pressure
that the volcano blows its top
but according to george there is a lot
left
unknown about the earth's core
if you were to shrink the earth down to
about the size of an apple
the crust portion would be about as
thick as the skin
and we have never gone deep enough to do
more than even just scratch the surface
of that skin
usually these two natural phenomena
don't happen in the same geographical
location
there aren't many volcanoes in tornado
alley after all but
there are places where the possibility
of the two colliding
become more of a reality italy
surprisingly gets quite a few tornadoes
as a matter of fact one was reported
there
just the other day so we've got a place
here in europe where they get
tornadoes from time to time and they
also have
active volcanoes mount etna is active
all the time
mount stromboli is erupting today it
erupts every single day and has been
doing so for 2000 years
all right so let's say that the largest
tornado
ever documented is going to hit mount
vesuvius
which is the volcano that destroyed the
city of pompeii
what would this catastrophe look like
so if you had a tornado that big as
strong as tornadoes get
between 250 to 300 plus miles an hour
air starts to basically starts to act
like a solid
it's so powerful so you take that and
you combine that with
a volcano
this tornado would pick up fire smoke
and ash from the volcano
creating a spinning vortex from hell
you've got sulfur gas you have volcanic
ash which is
microscopic shards of basaltic glass
just the ash alone being whipped at
those speeds
would sand blast your skin completely
off of your body
in seconds it's a level of destruction
that
is difficult for the human brain to
comprehend
but what about the lava lava
is melted rock and it's three times
denser than water so it's quite heavy
different kinds of volcanoes eject lava
of
different thicknesses vesuvius
is a stratovolcano which means it's made
up of many layers of
hardened magma volcanic ash and material
created from volcanic eruptions called
tephra stratovolcanoes have slow-moving
lava that
hardens before it spreads very far
unfortunately
stratovolcanoes also tend to erupt
violently during the eruption of
vesuvius back in back in roman times
it was a plinian eruption there's a
style of eruption where you have these
massive explosions
you have rocks you've got chunks of lava
now they're being whipped around
by 300 mile per hour winds
so we're talking the worst place in the
world to be
and that's not all like a fire tornado
a lava nato would spread hot ash and
magma
over the surrounding area setting it
ablaze
golf ball-sized hail debris and hardened
lava could rip through trees
buildings and cars its core could reach
temperatures
of 1093 degrees
burning anything it touches to a crisp
it is possible that a tornado could
strike a volcano like vesuvius
the the odds are infinitesimally small
but it's not zero
well that's good news but what about a
volcano creating
its own tornado volcanoes are so
powerful that they can create their own
weather
as a volcano spews hot gases and molten
lava
the surrounding temperature increases
rapidly
this forces cold air to rise and stretch
out into a column
creating a massive cloud formation
something similar happened in 2020 in
the california wildfires
i'll let george explain during the
california wildfires we had
an interesting situation where the fire
was so intense
that the heat coming off the fire
created an updraft
that formed what we call a pyrocumulus
cloud
the cloud grew so big it turned into a
thunderstorm a pyrocumulonimbus cloud
and then it started to spin so now we
had this
supercell thunderstorm that was
literally created
by the wildfire and that storm
produced an ef-3 tornado
so hypothetically something similar
could happen over a volcano as
it creates its own weather and if the
wind over a volcano suddenly changes
direction
and increases in speed the column
of colder air could begin to rotate
creating a tornado
thankfully this destructive storm has a
short lifespan
like a normal tornado the lava nato
would only last around
20 minutes it would also have a limited
range
because it's created by the unique
weather hovering over a volcano
it wouldn't be able to travel very far
once the lava nato moves away from the
volcano's hot gases
it would start to break up but the fires
it started
would still be raging
okay we've talked a lot about tornadoes
in volcanoes but
what would happen if a hurricane hit an
active volcano
hurricanes are much larger and longer
lasting than tornadoes
with a horizontal reach of over 1600
kilometers
and wind speeds up to 252 kilometers per
hour
it's much more likely that an active
volcano and
a hurricane would combine
but surprisingly not much would happen
other than the normal destruction caused
by hurricane that is
because a hurricane is so much larger
than a volcano
they would have very little effect on
each other if the active volcano is
large enough and
we're talking massive here it could make
the hurricane
bigger and stronger and the hurricane
could spread the volcano's dangerous
volcanic ash
further away but that pales in
comparison to the effects
of a lava nato there are about 1500
active volcanoes on earth and
each of them could create a lava nato
during an eruption
and what's even more dangerous than a
volcano
creating a lava nato
those volcanoes erupting at the same
time
but that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
you